welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Star Wars Episode nine the rides
of Skywalker released a final trailer
and I feel real bad for joking after the
previous trailer that red-eyed Threepio
had just inhaled the wrong stop at the
sauna Burning Man because apparently
that redness is droid blood kidding
aside I got an actual theory for what
the hell's going on with Threepio here
which I will get to as I break down this
trailer shot-by-shot for all the Easter
eggs and visual clues that you might
have overlooked spoiler warning the gays
sitting my speculation into being too
accurate or if my excitement that's too
genuine because I'm a wittle boy when it
comes to these things alright let's get
started it's an indistinct okay the
trailer opens with a calm nature shot a
lush jungle followed by surprise ray
dropping a helmet and running from what
looks like a combat remote droid now
past Star Wars new trilogy trailers have
opened with similar reveal shots for the
force awakens trailer it was a comp and
across the jakku desert then ben and if
you remember for the last Jedi trailer
it was a calm close-up of a boulder and
then ray hand this jungle appears to be
the same location ray hugs Leia in other
footage and the place where she caught
her lightsaber in the previous trailer
some are saying we could be returning to
Endor since the ruins of the second
death star appeared to factor into this
movie's plot and Endor was the nearest
surface in that splash zone this helmet
at two drops might be similar to the
helmet that Luke used while training
with one of those droids but this helmet
looks a lot different actually kind of
similar to the rebel helmets in
returning the Jedi on Endor now it's not
clear why she is running from a Jedi
equivalent of a speed bag though based
on the first teaser ray alone trying to
outrun threats seems to be something
she'll be doing a lot and Rises
Skywalker
there's this glorious midair match cut
as Rey leaps landing now inside what
looks like the Death Star wreckage that
we've seen other shots of all this
evokes the first images we saw of Rey in
the force awakens acrobatically scaling
the inside of a wrecked Star Destroyer
notice that Rey where's this backpack
that we saw her carrying in the previous
trailer as she gazed out at this
wreckage perhaps is a breathing
apparatus that allows her to dive into
submerged regions or just a fancy pouch
to contain what she
seeking here more thoughts on that as we
move on horse brush together
good people will fight if we leave them
and this clip fin looks through
binoculars on what looks like the desert
planet personna maybe spotting the
pursuers who chased them on that skiff
in other shots then Rey runs along the
ridge of the struggle planet and while
Endor seems like a place that could show
up in this movie endures terrain was
that of the Northern California redwood
forest this looks more rugged and
tropical like just over that Ridge could
be Wakanda this just doesn't look like
the same planet as a coastline that
faced the Death Star wreckage now Poe
gives a speech to a group of resistance
pilots he's joined by thin chewy
Threepio Lando Calrissian my man you can
also see a Mon Calamari behind Lando
that is actually the late Admiral
Ackbar's son
Aftab who has just introduced in the age
of resistance prelude comic also among
them could be wedge antilles who
according to Denis Lawson
will also return for this film notice
that several of the fighters appear to
be consistently in each other with hands
on shoulders this moment could be poe
sharing the news that general Leia
Organa has passed cry there's also a
shot of Rose Tico and behind her is
dominic monaghan character a still
unnamed resistance fighter Rose is still
wearing the medallion necklace that she
shared with her sister the bomber page
Tico who died early on in the last Jedi
Pavan Chui turn to face us and Poe has a
black armband wrapped around his farm
which could signify mourning for the
late general Organa the three stay
before this orange fighter
according to toys this is Poe's new
x-wing or sex swing probably Finn's
nickname for it what they share jackets
and I just realized that sex swing
sounds like sex swing and let's swing on
to the next clip
[Music]
and no one does
[Music]
but I do
here a cruiser brushes the treetops and
then ray stands atop the trench at the
Deathstar wreckage as huge waves crash
over her the detail of this shot is
insane
Naaman behind ray is streaks with rest
like a capsized battleship poking out of
the water exposed to the elements also
as the rain and ocean spray soaks ray
the droplets of water sizzle and
vaporized as they hit her lights per
blade kylo approaches ready to duel and
note that Ray no longer has that
backpack that she appeared to have in
the other shots of this location perhaps
whatever she found she is hidden from
kylo in this moment and that's the
treasure that they're fighting over
moving on
and to know
you're coming together
whoa baby okay dozens of typewriters
closed in on this flat earthers wet
dream an iceberg II disk planet both
faces have structures built on top
smokestacks that looks like in the top
base elaborate skyscraper structures
carved into the ice on the bottom
actually I'm wondering if this shot is
actually upside down and the longer
version will rotate to reveal this is
the bottom side a pretty cool visual
trick by JJ Abrams because if you think
about it TIE fighters are symmetrical we
wouldn't know which way we were oriented
it's space I'm wondering if this is
actually the new ice planet could Jimmy
get Jimmy whatever the surface of which
I think we have seen in other footage
I'll try to piece all this together in a
bit but first we gotta talk about this
gnarly sith throne when the Lightning
illuminates it you can see that it's
made of stone perhaps from the volcanic
rock as the ancient Sith temple on
Mustafar not sure but Lucasfilm creative
art manager Bill szostak tweeted
confirming that this drones design was
based on Ralph McQuarrie's 1981 concept
art sketches a Palpatine's throne and
returned the Jedi next there's a shot of
a Star Destroyer rising from this ice
surface oh my god now this is part of
the fleet of old-school Star Destroyers
we saw in the previous trailer notice
the spherical shield generator that's
old-school baby we've also been
speculating how or why anyone could have
built a fleet of massive star destroyers
in secret without the New Republic
knowing about it or the first order
wanting to use it perhaps the answer is
in the ice a backup
fleet of super star destroyers hidden in
the ice waiting to be activated their
rise could account for the cracking ice
planet surface that we've seen in past
trailer shots but then we move on to the
most detail packed shot of this trailer
the resistance fleet Avenger is
assembling pretty much every ship in the
shot is an Easter Egg I'm gonna point
out all the ones that I spotted but
first before we continue thanks to our
sponsor ray Khan for helping us make
this breakdown
ray Khan makes these sleek comfortable
wireless headphones that are way more
affordable than any of the other options
out there they come in a range of fun
colors and patterns and a variety of fit
options so they're both stylish and
discreet no dangling wires or stems that
you know in the past have left me
feeling tangled and cross-wired kind of
like Threepio and every damn movie Rey
Khan's latest model
25 is their best one yet it's got six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit it also comes in new fun
colorways you just paired them with your
device and you pop them in and you're
good to listen to whatever music or
podcasts you want just like Snoop Dogg
can Who I am told is obsessed with these
it's one of the infinite things Snoopy
and I have in common
Raik on earbuds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market they sound just as
amazing as top audio brands that you
know and click on the link in the
description below to get 15% off your
order okay back to the resistance fleet
Easter eggs front center obviously
that's the Falcon but to its immediate
right is the ghost from Star Wars rebels
appearing again after its law cameo in
rogue one also from rebels behind the
Falcons radar dish as it lowers in a
frame which that radar dish has been
reattached that is the shadow caster now
also visible in this frame I think
that's Raven's claw for it was the nerd
house in the Harry Potter world the
Ravens claw was kyle katarn ship in the
jedi knight video games as well as the
outrider that would be - renders whitey
2400 light freighter from the shadows of
the Empire games in the distant
background I think there are some liquor
Hulk battleships from the Clone Wars era
maybe some mana calamari cruisers and
among all this you should also be able
to make out a u2 60d you win the Corvis
from battlefront to a pail to class
forget from Clone Wars a whole bunch of
Nebulon B frigates some MC 75 s a
hammerhead Corvette that was one that we
saw in rogue one red and green nosed
consular class ships the raha Tok from
the Battle of Endor returned the Jedi a
belying class heavy freighter that was a
ship that Han and Chewie were initially
on in the force awakens a defender class
Corvette from the Old Republic games a
Lancer class pursuit craft from rebels
and recently revealed in the last Jedi
an mg 100 star fortress SF 17 bomber a
vac B or class cargo frigate and a free
Virgilia class Blanc ER Buster let me
know if he spotted in the others here
and with the shot of raid suey Po and
thin and Threepio in the Falcon cockpit
we move on
is your undoing
what are you doing there or Threepio
taking one last look sir at my friend so
ray and kylo battle on the death star
wreckage followed by a quick shot of a
massive explosion in space now in the
foreground of that explosion you can
make out a triangular shape of a Star
Destroyer hmm hold on to that thought
but then after we see the boat that ray
uses to make it out of that wreckage our
hearts become wrecked
thanks to Threepio rewiring the back of
his head is this little dude his name is
Babu Frick and and Zelly enjoyed sment
who works with these spice runners of
Kissimmee one of them presumably is Zuri
bliss Carrie Russell's character who
appears in the scene pah-wraiths in
chewie bb-8 do and r2 are all watching
on here so obviously this is a very
significant moment probably the most
significant person in the scene
background of this droid repair shop a
deactivated battle droid for the
prequels remember those where are you
taking them Rutter anyway Threepio
appears to be saying goodbye to his
print why all might not be lost folks
because perhaps Threepio could be doing
what el 337 did with the Millennium
Falcon and solo a Star Wars story
interfacing plugging the Droid CPU into
a ship to become its sort of operating
system so the way the Falcons
personality is technically that of
fleabag may be now three POS personality
could live on in another ship lady the
ruins of the Death Star 2 or one of the
new Star Destroyers that also seem to be
tucked away on consuming by plugging
Threepio into one of those ships maybe
they will try to use that ships weaponry
on the other Star Destroyers look folks
if we're gonna have to say goodbye to
Threepio here what a way for the guy to
go out and it would leave r2 as the one
survivor of all nine films to tell the
tale to the next generation via bleeps
and whistles that all translate into
extreme profanity
on to the next clip confronting fear the
destiny of it
your destiny all right here Pope and
Chewie blast their way down a hall
perhaps on board of one of those
stardestroyers a shot choreography here
is really low angle with first order
stormtroopers dropping in front of us
it's as if the camera is like on a
rolling mouse droid so cool bb-8
punctures that yellow gas canister is a
flare to throw up their pursuers I'm
personna Lando and Chewie here back in
the Falcon late a pilot in it just as he
did the Battle of Endor then a y-wing
barrel rolls up to a Star Destroyer
which has a massive cannon on its
underbelly
perhaps these new star destroyers are
each equipped with a Death Star level
super laser which you think about it
unleashed all over the galaxy that would
make this entire fleet an uncontrollable
apocalyptic threat moving on
[Music]
the section features Ben Poe bb-8 and
Jana that's Naomi hockey's character in
a cavalry charge now I'm not sure what
these galloping horse creatures are some
upset they look like the poor duck of
Endor I'm not sure they appear to be on
the outer whole of a Star Destroyer so
wherever they are it must be low enough
within an atmosphere for them to breathe
or maybe since Leia MARY POPPINS to
through space everything is just crazy
now Rey and kylo faced each other in
this familiar spot this is the ruins of
the second Death Star throne room where
Palpatine presided over the duel between
Luke and Vader and I think the thing Rey
is seeking is some remnant of either
Vader or Palpatine that is left in this
location because after this is the most
interesting shot of the trailer ray and
kylos lightsabers shattering the statue
which to me looks kind of like a Vader's
shape notice that kylos helmet is back
on fuse back together as we saw in the
other trailer footage but more
importantly Rey is holding a stone
dagger what the Horcrux now some are
saying this could be the dagger of
mortis an ancient mystical weapon from
Star Wars the Clone Wars
according to lore it's connected to the
godlike beings the father the daughter
and the son it's a fascinating
sunday-school story we'll see if Raisa
Skywalker will draw on the lore
presented in the animated series to this
extent but this dagger could also be the
way Palpatine lived on like his essence
perhaps possessing it as an old force
artifact something that dead Sethe have
been known to do in Star Wars Canon this
white tinted setting is unlike anything
we've seen in these prequels though
notice that line and dot lighting on the
walls does evoke the set design of the
original trilogy maybe it's a vault
containing Palpatine's or Vader's old
SIF tokens and kylo and Ray are fighting
for that dagger with their blades
shattering all the other artifacts in
this chamber then there's another angle
of the cavalry charge that shows an
x-wing end of b-wing dogfighting with
some Thai fighters on the dozens of Star
Destroyers on the horizon notice that
all of them appear to have that bulge a
big weapon we got a close-up on their
undercarriage earlier they're all
packing it and then before we move on
Rey backs away in fear looking up at
what's that in the foreground folks that
looks like a black hooded cloak I think
we're looking at Palpatine here now this
person is seated high above Rey based on
its motion he could be either
in a floating chair or it's some kind of
mech droid form perhaps to Ray's journey
to recover the artifact awakened
Palpatine on catching me along with the
remnants of his scorched earth
contingency operation cinder which
consisted a backup fleet of super star
destroyers which case it could be all on
Threepio of all people to save us on to
the final clip the force will be with
you
so ray apparently on the ice planet
surface based on those lightning flashes
lightsaber drawn here's the inspiration
voices of two mentors Luke Skywalker
Scherzer the force will be with you and
whispering always is the voice of Carrie
Fisher Leia now JJ Abrams said that he
would be repurposing footage and audio
of the late Carrie Fisher with her
family's blessing from past films of
force awakens in the last Jedi as
opposed to abusing the effects magic to
try to resurrect her this exact word
always might have been of an alternate
take of this line from the force awakens
and now I'm more upset what do you think
three Pio's fate will be in the rise of
Skywalker comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at in boss and if you enjoy
these breakdowns of all the details that
you missed in Star Wars stuff one big
project that we've been wanting to do is
a rewatch series of all the past films
the classic original trilogy and the
prequel trilogy one way that you can
help us fit this series into our
overpacked schedule is by becoming a
patron of our new expansion to new
rockstars Digital Studios in RDS Nura
guards with enough patrons we will be
able to do classic Star Wars breakdowns
in the weeks leading up to rise of
Skywalker Plus patrons will get access
to an exclusive monthly bonus breakdown
if you can help us out check out the
link in the description and a big thanks
to our past patreon Jake storm thanks
buddy
thank you for joining me and hey if
Threepio is interfacing with the ship
let us hope that his AI ends up getting
transferred to the Falcon because just
the thought of Anthony Daniels bickering
with fleabag for ever and ever
and the coolest ship ever
[Music]